SPEAKER 1: So let's
start at the beginning.
So Arno, in the late
'80s, early '90s,
you were a founding
member of what
went on to become one
of the largest hate
groups in the country.
Tell us about your experience
in Milwaukee, growing up,
and that led to being involved
in an organization like that.
ARNO MICHAELIS: What's
interesting about my experience
is that on paper,
I would have been
like the last kid
you would think
that would go that direction.
When I was researching
for my first book,
I was talking to a lot of people
who were in the gang with me
and who had also gotten
out, and in the process
of doing that, I was asking
about their childhoods,
asking about things that
they'd been through.
And just about all of them
had horrific childhoods.
There was missing parents.
There was physical abuse.
There was poverty.
In my case, I grew up in a nice
house, in a nice neighborhood,
never went hungry,
never took a beating.
My parents were together.
They both loved me very much.
They let me know
that all the time.
In fact, all the
adults in my life
were just showering me with
affirmation and positivity.
But I grew up in an
alcoholic household,
and my parents fought a lot.
And my mom was
always stressed out,
trying to keep things running.
And my mom's misery
was very plain to me.
And instead of being a
good kid, and being like,
hey, mom, I love
you, how can I help,
I would be distancing myself
from her, distancing myself
from my dad, from all these
adults who were supporting me,
which of course,
made me suffer more
and led me to start lashing out
at other kids which I quickly
got a habit for.
I got a habit for
people being afraid
of me, a habit for the thrill
of teachers freaking out,
of causing havoc in
otherwise orderly places.
And like any kind of substance
abuse, what gets you high
the first time is old
hat 10 times later.
You got to keep escalating it.
So my anti-social
behavior escalated
from being a bully
on the school bus
to fights in the school yard
to breaking and entering,
burglary, vandalism,
fighting in the street.
I started drinking
myself when I was 14.
The first time I drank, I
drank until I passed out,
and I drank like that
for another 20 years.
By the time I'm 16, I'm
a full-blown alcoholic.
I am very conditioned
to violence.
It's like second nature to me.
And hate is just another
part of the thrill,
like just, oh, I
hate the school.
I hate the cops.
I hate society.
I hate the government.
Like it was just
part of the habit
that I was really addicted to.
And so that's who I was when
I heard white power skinhead
music that was really fast
and aggressive, which I loved.
I was in a punk before that,
and I loved the hardcore fast
break stuff kind of punk.
And this was the
same kind of music,
but the lyrics were about race
and nation and blood and soil,
all these very seductive
and romantic themes,
and the same themes, really,
that Adolf Hitler used
to twist the mind of so
many millions of Germans
in World War II.
Plus, it really
pissed people off.
Nothing pisses people
off like a swastika.
And I was just really in the
business of pissing people off.
That's all I wanted to do.
So my initial involvement in
these white power skinhead
hate groups was to get
a rise out of people.
It was to repulse civil society
and to provoke hostility,
to provoke fights.
So that's what got me into it.
Me and a couple of friends
started this white power
skinhead gang in Milwaukee.
I was already in
punk bands and pretty
acclimated to screaming loud
and getting people crazy.
So we started our
own skinhead band,
and we were like a
magnet for pissed
off white kids that just
came from every direction
to be part of what
we were doing.
And as we radiated
hostility into the world,
the world reflected it
back to us, and oftentimes
in multiples.
And within a few
months, my best friend,
who I'd started the
gang and the band with,
went to prison for shooting
a kid who came into a drive
by our house.
Within a couple of years,
another very good friend
of mine was shot and
killed in a street fight
as he was out practicing
hate and violence,
as I had taught him to do.
And rather than see these
bad things happening
as wake-up calls, we
saw them as validation
of our paranoid narrative.
So rather than wake up
and come to my senses
when my friend got murdered,
it wasn't his fault
that he was out marching around
with a swastika on his jacket
and picking fights with people
that led to the shooting that
killed him.
It was the Jews'
fault for bringing
all these black and
brown people here.
And so that whole
way of thinking
is this constant
process of spinning
whatever's happening in the
world to suit your narrative.
And it took a ton of
energy and really added
to this growing
sense of exhaustion
that eventually led me out.
SPEAKER 1: And Pardeep, you
had a different upbringing
in Milwaukee.
So talk about your
time and really--
I know you were a police
officer for a while-- to where
you are today, but really
the growing up in Milwaukee
and what it was like
for you and your family.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Yeah,
for us in our family,
I came to the states
when I was six years old.
And I had sort of a typical--
and now, I want to
use the word typical
right now because I think the
time and space that we exist
in right now calls for a
unity of just immigration
and immigration patterns,
demographic change.
And so I grew up as
your typical immigrant.
I came here when I was six, not
a lot of money in our pockets.
My dad had $10 in his pocket--
maybe $35 in his pocket--
probably a little bit more,
but just scratching, clawing.
We moved to
Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
At that time, in the 1980s,
Milwaukee was a thriving city.
Soon as we got
here, there were be
this sort of job exodus,
employment exodus
in the city of
Milwaukee that would
lead to kind of an illegal
economy, and just an economy--
there goes the crime rates.
There goes drug raids.
There goes these
shootings, homicides.
And before long, we were
caught in the hairs of trying
to find a safe place to live.
I remember my parents
moving around quite a bit.
We moved from the
north side of Milwaukee
to the east side of Milwaukee,
east side of Milwaukee
to the south side,
west side, and really
just going on this
whole journey of trying
to find a safe place
to raise their kids.
As I grew up, I
grew up and there
wasn't a lot of Punjabi people
at that time in the '80s,
especially not in
Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
I think there was about
four or five families,
and that, not having
somebody or some people
to call your own led
to this feeling of,
I wasn't enough, led
I'm not black
enough to be black.
I'm not Latino
enough to be Latino.
I'm not white
enough to be white.
I'm not American enough
to call myself American.
And in a weird kind of way,
I wasn't even Indian enough
to call myself Indian.
I can, as a 42-year-old grown up
man, can see the beauty in that
now because all of that led to
me being able to embrace myself
and me.
But at that time,
growing up, it really
led to a sense of, who am I?
What am I?
What do I represent?
And that led to me
saying, OK, you know what?
I want to do something
with my life that's
going to mean something to
the country that gave me hope.
And I dreamt about
being a police officer.
I became the first
one in our family
to graduate from college, became
a police officer in Milwaukee,
and just really
noticing some of the--
and as I was growing
up, I thought the world
to be black and white, right?
We think in simple terms of,
I can give back to the society
if I can keep good people
safe from bad folks.
But we know the realities of
policing are not that simple.
There's a lot of gray,
and over time, that gray
became too much to stomach.
And so I became a
educator working
with at-risk high school
youth in the same neighborhood
that I was policing.
The neighborhood
that I was policing
has a documentary about it.
It's called 53206.
It is one of the most violent
neighborhoods in Milwaukee.
So the entirety of
my policing career
was getting dope, getting
guns, getting arrests,
and yet, throughout
that entire five years,
I never wrote one parking
ticket or one speeding ticket.
It was just really just
running and gunning.
And seeing that from that
sense of a police officer,
and then working
as a teacher, you
see a different
level of intimacy.
Now you're working
with youth, attempting
to try to work with them
before they get into this life.
And you get to know parents and
you get to know grandparents.
And you have to develop
relationships, probably
something that I should have
done as a police officer
anyways.
But we didn't live
in that culture
of getting to know the
neighborhood you were policing
in.
It was really just running,
gunning, arresting,
and that was that.
And that was my life
before August 5th.
SPEAKER 1: Well, that's
exactly what I want to get to.
I think part of
what connects you,
and we'll get to
your first meeting
and how you guys
became friends, but I
think August 5, 2012,
is the significant day.
Do you mind sharing
your experience
on that day, what happened,
for everyone that doesn't know,
and what was going
through your mind?
And then, Arno, I'll ask
the same question to you
after, too.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Sure, sure.
So yeah, August 5th, and when
I think back to the August 5th,
I mean, it's August right now.
And we think about how
warm it is and I just
think about how nice
it was at that time
to live in this world of
being oblivious, I would say,
and taking things for granted.
At that time, I was married.
I had two kids.
It was summer, summer
vacation for us.
Career was going great.
We bought a house.
My wife was working.
And I thought that
everything was just--
we had achieved pretty
much the American dream.
My dad at that time
was 65 years old.
He basically collected one
month of social security,
and he was kind of
joking around about it.
He was like, wow,
like when you turn
a certain age in this
country, they give you money
and they give you insurance
and things like that.
So he was just really
celebrating it.
And we, at that time, were
really like, we've achieved.
We've made it.
The entire family
has made it, right,
from having a
little bit of money
and being immigrants to saying,
OK, now both my sons have
graduated school.
I'm collecting social security.
My dad had made it with
the small businesses,
and we were in the
summer of that.
And then, this is when,
on that August morning,
a person who was part of the
gang that Arno helped start
told us, in not so much
words, but with gunshots,
that we weren't entitled
to that American dream,
that that dream was not really
meant for people like us.
And he, that morning, took
the lives of six people.
One of those people was my
father and temple president,
Satwant Singh
Kaleka, and I mean,
it was only the fortunate
circumstances of my daughter
forgetting something
at the house that
made us turn around and
be 10 minutes late getting
to the gurdwara, which
we call the Sikh temple.
And so even in the
moment when I found out
that there was a shooting at the
temple, and what had happened,
there was mixed
feelings that I had
because once the police officer
told me what's going on,
I knew that both my parents
were inside the temple.
And I asked him, I said,
when did this happen?
And he says, 10
minutes ago it started.
The scene is not secure.
And at that time, all
these different emotions
start to come over you.
And for those that
have experienced trauma
in their life or
pain in their life
can maybe resonate
with this and say,
OK, there's a feeling of relief.
There's a feeling of
relief, believe it or not,
of like, OK, I'm not dead.
I'm not inside there, and my
children are not inside there.
There's a feeling of guilt,
the guilt being around,
maybe I didn't do enough when
I could have done enough.
Maybe I just took
things for granted.
And I settled into this
domesticated life of,
I have mine, so you know what?
I don't got to worry about them.
And all these other
different emotions
are happening at the same
time, anger, frustration,
helplessness, the what ifs
that haunt you, the what
ifs of like, would
the police have--
and that day, there's so much
that we were not privy to,
we were not given, and
say, OK, you know what?
We were finding out
in real time what
was happening with
our loved ones,
and not through law enforcement.
We were finding out
through Twitter.
We were finding out through
social media what is going on
with our loved ones.
And the question that kept
coming up to me was like,
would they do this if
this demographic was not
a small demographic to America?
What if this demographic had a
little bit more political power
than our demographic?
Would the police have gone in
quicker if there was different
folks, if it was a church
rather than a temple?
And that really eats at you.
And I think like, that's been
the part, for me and Arno,
that's been our inspiration,
that's to say, you know what?
Forgiveness is going to
look a lot like vengeance.
And we're going to
be vengeful and say
that nobody is
going to ever have
to have this feeling of not
being worth enough to save.
SPEAKER 1: And Arno, so what
was your experience like when
you heard that a group
that you helped found
was basically claiming
responsibility
for such a horrific act?
ARNO MICHAELIS: I'll never
forget Sunday, August 5, 2012.
In addition to being a
former white supremist,
I'm a former IT consultant.
I don't like to talk about
that as it's too dramatic,
but I was actually doing IT work
for a client down in Illinois.
I'd work on weekends
when I could
because the end users aren't
in my way and vise versa.
And of course, while
servers are rebooting
and progress bars are
growing, I'm just--
I'm probably the only IT
guy that ever did this,
but I'd be like dicking around
on social media and whatnot.
And I remember a Twitter feed,
just the hashtag Sikh temple
shooting.
And it's just pouring
down my screen.
And it's saying multiple gunmen.
Nobody knows how
many are dead yet.
Sikh temple in Wisconsin.
And like so many people before
August 5th, so many Americans,
I had no idea who Sikhs were.
Like, oh, those are the guys who
drive the taxis with the thing
on the back with the sword.
I didn't know anything
about what Sikh was about,
but I did know that
because of who Sikhs were,
because they were so
visibly different than even
other people of
color in the states,
I just had this
sinking feeling that I
had something to do with
this, that my old ideology had
something to do with this.
There was white supremacy
involved in one way or another
and very possibly directly
motivating the shooter.
So from my client's
office, and by the way,
this client is
still a good friend
and aware that I was doing
this on billable time,
but I recorded a video
response to the shooting,
and really, just first of
all, said how devastated.
I was to imagine people who
have lost their fathers,
three boys lost their mom.
Like there's a grandpa
there who was killed,
and really feeling
that kind of suffering.
I wanted to convey
that in the video,
how dedicated I was to bearing
witness to the suffering
and also to burying as
much of it as I could.
And then, I went on about how,
when things like this happen,
we really have to let
compassion be our vengeance.
We have to let
what's most beautiful
about our human experience
come to the rescue
of this situation.
And I went on a bit
about how we really
got to see ourselves
in each other,
no matter what, if we're
Democrats and Republicans,
or if we're black and white,
or we're rich and poor,
like whatever.
We still got to see that
we're all human beings first
and foremost.
And then, I went home and just
glued myself to the media,
and by the end of
the night, it was
revealed that the shooter
was a white supremist,
an affiliated white supremist.
They didn't say his
name, so that night I
lay awake all night wondering
if this was somebody
that I had recruited into
that narrative who had just
murdered six people, or if
it was someone who I knew.
The next morning, the
guy's name was announced.
His name was Wade Michael Page.
They announced his background.
He was from Colorado
originally, then
North Carolina, and
only recently Milwaukee.
Even though so much of my time
back in the hate group days
was literally
hazed by alcohol, I
might have met
this guy in person.
They later revealed that he got
radicalized while in the United
States Army, and came
out of the Army in 1998
a full-blown white
power skinhead.
I was able to rule
that out also,
that I didn't know
this guy personally.
But it didn't really change the
urgency that I felt to respond
and the responsibility
that I felt
to help transform this
atrocity into something that
would actively counter hate and
violence from that day forward.
SPEAKER 1: So now, you too
are very good friends now.
But I would love to hear how you
decided to meet the first time.
What were the
expectations going in,
and what was it like
meeting the first time,
coming from such different
backgrounds and such
a unique connection
between the two of you?
PARDEEP KALEKA: Yeah.
So after the shooting happened--
my dad was temple
president and he
was president for 15 years,
which is a long time according
to Sikh Indian politics.
The president of any church,
synagogue, mosque, like Google
aura, right?
So I mean, his
dream was basically
to make a sanctuary where
people, Sikhs, could come to.
And within that time, he did.
He fulfilled what
he needed to do.
And he died in the place
that he helped build.
No bigger martyrdom.
We call it sahidi.
Some people call it kabani,
but no bigger sacrifice
than a person
could do than that.
And in fact, I had a lot
of people who came up to me
and were like, don't feel bad.
Don't feel sad.
Just, your dad did
what he needed to do.
And no better death than to
die that death of a martyr.
With that said, that puts
a lot of pressure on you
as the oldest son, and
puts a lot of pressure
on what you need to do.
So my personal grief,
my personal healing,
could not actually start.
I had to figure out
logistics for other families
who had lost their loved ones.
Most of these families
did not understand
the culture of America.
So I was old enough
to understand
the culture of America, how do
we do funeral proceedings, who
pays for what, the
logistics of everything.
How do we raise funds?
This thing that I felt,
I felt in my mind,
was just to dive into work.
With that said, we basically put
on a brave face for the world,
right?
But at the same time, I
think I was faking it.
I think I wasn't truly--
I was still bitter.
I was still upset.
I was still gritting my teeth
at every interview where they
would talk about forgiveness.
And I'd be like, oh, fah.
Yes.
Let me talk about this.
And that was my honest truth.
I did a thing for law
enforcement one time
and I could barely
get through the talk
because I was so bitter.
And when we were doing this,
we were approached by every--
you name it-- gun
rights to education
to everything,
immigration, xenophobia.
And my inspiration
to reach out to Arno
was to figure out, OK, why
did this person do this?
We weren't getting answers.
So the best person
that can explain it
is a person that has
lived that lifestyle
and had started that same
organization to find out
why somebody would do
something like this.
And I didn't know
it at that time,
but that would lead me to
my own personal feeling.
Arno's not only my
friend and my brother.
Arno is my counselor,
my therapist, and that's
a lot coming from a therapist.
ARNO MICHAELIS: I'm a therapist.
PARDEEP KALEKA: And
I think we talk.
We talk every week and
we talk about things that
are unrelated to August 5th.
We're genuinely friends.
We're genuinely brothers.
This man comes over to my house,
babysits the kids, takes them,
and all of that
to say, you really
need to challenge-- we need
to challenge ourselves.
And not to say that I'm not
putting any blame on the Wage
Pages of the world.
But if I put all the
blame and all the emphasis
on the Wade Pages, the
white supremacists,
the other people in
the world, then I
continue to take my
life for granted.
And I think the biggest part
of forgiveness is to say,
you know what?
Honestly, if this wouldn't have
happened, you would've went on
and you would have
lived your life,
and you wouldn't
have appreciated
every single conversation
as much as you do now,
every single relationship
that you do now.
You probably wouldn't
tuck your kids in at night
and hang around their
bed for an hour,
and just sit there and watch
them sleep because you would
have took that for granted.
You probably wouldn't
have made love--
oh, sorry-- made love with
a sense of appreciation.
It's OK.
We all know we do it.
But in a way, I think the
forgiveness was really
just like, OK, I need to take
control of my own personal life
and our relationship
definitely helped that.
SPEAKER 1: So when
was the first meeting?
Talk us through sitting
down the first time.
So the first meeting,
well, the first time
we talked, we were both
working for a global think tank
called Against
Violent Extremism.
And I reached out--
ARNO MICHAELIS: Founded
in part by Google Ideas,
which was kind of exciting.
Thank you.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Yeah,
Google put us together.
ARNO MICHAELIS: Yeah, exactly.
PARDEEP KALEKA: That was
our Tinder back then.
Sorry.
I don't even want to get--
So the first time
we reached out,
we connected the same way that
everybody connects these days,
digitally.
And then we texted.
We talked.
And just being
able to talk to him
was uplifting because I
was getting to a point
where reality was hitting.
It was about two months
after the shooting.
Reality was really
starting to set in.
Dad's not coming home.
And these children
are never going
to see their grandfather again.
He had two grandkids
at the time.
They would ask about him.
And how do you explain this?
It's tough to explain.
So my mom was a widow.
It's like we're figuring out all
this stuff, but it's like, OK,
after the inspiration of
cameras and things being there,
and you getting to put on--
and it is a privilege to
be able to put on a brave
face for the world, right?
There's a sense of purpose to
that, but then, reality hits.
And you go back home
and the loneliness--
first thing you think
about is the shooting.
First thing you think
about when you go to sleep
or when you wake up in the
morning is what just happened.
Did I just dream this?
Did this really
just happen to us?
And really, the world happening
to you is a victimizing place.
Just think that the world
can just happen to you
and not happen for you,
is a sense of, oh, my god.
Like what can I do about this?
So reaching out to Arno
and hearing his voice,
and just the first
time talking, we
decided to sit down and
then really just conversate,
face to face.
When we decided to
do that, I was still
gauging, from my experience with
him over the phone or via text,
whether he was still
a white supremacist,
whether a person could
really go from being
a white supremacist to
not having that ideology,
or whether it was just
so ingrained within us
that somebody could not
separate themselves from that.
So I'm still gauging
this, and I'm asking him,
like, where do you
want to go out to eat?
And I swear, if you
would have said,
I want to go get beer
and brats, or like I
want to go to a tavern--
because Milwaukee's
full of taverns--
ARNO MICHAELIS: For sauerkraut
and wienerschnitzel.
PARDEEP KALEKA: --if you
were to talk like that,
I would have been like, bro,
I got to like watch the kids.
I would have put the
whole kid excuse on.
But he says, I like Thai food.
You like Thai food?
And I was like, yeah,
yeah, I can do Thai food.
Cool.
And in the back of
my mind, I was really
thinking, man, he
must have changed
because white people can
barely handle spicy food,
let alone white supremacists.
I know they can't
handle spicy food.
ARNO MICHAELIS: It's true.
PARDEEP KALEKA: So that
helped ease my- like,
OK, well, we're
going to do this.
But as the weeks
started to move along
and we started to get
towards that date of meeting,
I started to tell my wife and
my mother and other family
members, and they would be
like, you lost your mind.
Something's going on with you.
Don't do this.
These people can't change.
And change is the most
inevitable thing in life.
Things are going to change.
We have to navigate that change.
That's how you all stay relevant
in the work that you do.
So we all stay relevant.
But with that said,
a lot of people
think that change can't
happen for certain people.
And I was just like, we have
a faith here who believes--
Sikhi actually is based in
the principle of oneness,
and that change
will happen, right,
but they're telling me, no, this
person hasn't changed and can't
change.
And as much as I didn't
want to believe it,
it starts to seep at your soul.
And so it starts
to seep and say,
well, maybe they might be right.
Maybe something is
going on with me.
I might be a little crazy
because I do hang around
and hug the kids
longer than I should.
Like people don't
normally do this.
They don't just hang out with
their kids and just like,
I want to hold you.
I want to love you, right?
So I started to think, maybe
this person hasn't changed.
And through all that--
me and Arno say it all time--
through all your
fears, be courageous.
Just keep testing it.
Be courageous.
The thing that you
sometimes don't want to do
is what you should be doing.
Try to say yes more
than you say no.
Obviously there are things
that you want to say no to,
but be courageous.
And so just keep going in
that sort of intention,
that spirit of
being courageous, we
find ourselves at this
restaurant together.
And the first time
that I saw him,
I was like, what am I going
to say to this person?
What do I really want to know?
What am I going to ask?
I get all this other
stuff is going on,
but now, we're face
to face, and what am I
really going to ask him?
And to my surprise, he was
kind of thinking the same way.
He was like, what do I
say to this person who
just lost their father?
I'm sorry?
I'm sorry would seem kind
of hollow at this point of I
helped to start this
organization that this guy
belonged to, and now
I'm sitting here,
and I'm facing the consequences
of actions that I thought that
I put way back there, but
knowing that I really can't.
Like stuff that we
have done in the past,
we still have to
be accountable for.
Forgiveness doesn't mean
that we just move on
and go forward with our life
without ever going back there
and saying, you know what?
There's some wounds.
There's some stuff back there.
Right?
Sometimes people say, well,
you know time heals all wounds.
That's the biggest crock
of shit I've ever heard.
Who made that saying?
Time does not heal all wounds.
In fact, sometimes, time
makes them worse, especially
in an infected wound.
Yes, we will go
on with our life,
and if we got something
wrong, we can pad around that,
and we can maneuver
our life around that.
But if you're still moving
your life around that,
this is still the focus.
That wound is still the focus.
Yeah, you've gone on, but
you haven't removed it.
And that's the thing.
Wounds do not heal with time.
They heal with time,
they heal with purpose,
they heal with
forgiveness, they heal
with a sense of consciousness.
They heal with honoring pain,
and the first time that we met,
that's who I met.
I met a person who said, listen,
we're going to honor this pain.
We're going to be conscious
about what this pain is from.
We're going to take
control of our lives.
And that's how healing
wounds really happens.
It's not just about time.
It's about consciousness.
It's about forgiveness.
It's about purpose.
ARNO MICHAELIS: And it was
actually a physical wound
that Pardeep incurred about
a week before that actually
was our icebreaker.
So like Par said, I was
freaked out going to meet him.
I was really honored
for the ability
to just offer myself
in service to Pardeep,
and to his community,
and to his family.
I was excited about that, but at
the same time, I'm intimidated.
Like where do I even begin?
And just like Par said, like,
what do you even-- like, hey,
I'm Arno.
Sorry about your dad.
Nothing I could have
thought of seemed right,
and I'm rarely at
a loss for words,
as you may have gathered.
But at the time, I
didn't know what to say.
I get in there early.
I get to the restaurant, and
this restaurant is like my jam.
I'm known to eat here
like five days a week.
I'm a curry fiend.
I no longer drink, so I
get a buzz through chili.
Like that's how I get messed up.
And this is some of
the spiciest food
I've had on the planet Earth.
And I love it that way.
And I know the owners.
I know the chefs
and all the servers.
They're all friends of mine.
And where I look back
to my past and a lot
of my hate and my violence
came from like a fear
of my vulnerabilities, since
I started meditating in 2009
and really studied
how my mind works
and how human
emotion works, I've
really just become very open
in my vulnerabilities, which
means I go to pieces
at the drop of a hat.
After the Sikh temple
shooting, I was doing media
for like eight to 10 hours
a day, and it was at a point
where I was transitioning
from the IT career
to a career as a
speaker and an author.
Things were really rough
for me, financially.
And all of a sudden, the eyes
of the entire world are upon me.
I'm doing CNN, MSNBC,
New York Times, LA Times,
Norwegian newspapers, Australian
radio, everything in between.
And I'm grateful I
had this opportunity
to bring a message of
compassion and an opportunity
to expose the toxicity of the
white supremist narrative,
and say all this stuff.
But at the same
time, the part of me
that hates myself, the part
of me that will never forgive
myself for what I've done
and who I've hurt, is saying,
yeah, Arno, go sell some books.
Go get some speaking gigs.
And it sucked.
By the end, Thursday
of that week,
I had a nervous breakdown.
I just lost it for hours.
I'm just sobbing.
And all I wanted to do was
go back to bones and servers
if it would bring
those six people back.
But that's obviously
not going to happen.
It's impossible.
And so I just had to cope.
And the following
Sunday, exactly
one week after the
shooting, I was
invited to come
speak at a vigil,
and I did a really
quick three-minute bit.
And a guy from
the Sikh coalition
came up to me, Jasmit
Singh, and he thanked me.
Like hey, man, I saw
you on media all week.
I saw you-- this
talk was amazing.
Thank you for your voice.
It means the world to us.
And I was just
floored that I could
be part of his healing process.
And then again, I'm
starting to get teary eyed,
and I go to pieces.
And I'm just like, I wish
there was more Sikhs here.
I hope more Sikhs
come to the country.
I was just so in awe
of the Sikh community,
and really, just, I wanted
more Sikhs everywhere.
Like our society, we
got to Sikh it up.
That's what we need.
And as I'm telling him
this, I'm like bawling.
I'm gushing tears.
I got snot flying everywhere.
And dude's got
this really-- he's
got this beautiful
tied silk turban on,
and he's got this beautiful
really expensive looking
silk suit.
And he comes and gives me a hug.
And I'm like, dude, I'm
getting snot on your suit.
I'm really sorry.
And he was like, naw, dude.
Don't worry about it, man.
It's cool.
It was all good.
And that was so uplifting to me.
And again, I'm like, OK, this
dude's community was assaulted.
He's comforting me.
Like what does that
tell you, especially
coming from this
narrative, saying,
oh, well, white
people are superior.
We're the superior
race, blah blah blah.
Who's superior in
that interaction?
Jasmit is far and away
the superior human being.
So going forward from there, I
kind of I got my shit together,
but going to meet
Pardeep, all this stuff
was coming back again.
And I was really
intimidated to meet him.
So I go in there.
I get in there early.
I'm talking to my friends,
King and Mary, the servers,
and Par comes in, and he
sees me talking to them.
King and Mary are Asian.
Go figure, at a Thai restaurant.
Par's like, oh, he's talking
to some Asians, so that's good.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Yeah.
ARNO MICHAELIS: It looks
like they're genuine friends.
So that's a good sign.
PARDEEP KALEKA: He hasn't
beaten them up yet.
ARNO MICHAELIS: Yeah, he
hasn't attacked anybody.
And so as he walks in,
he's got this piece of tape
above his eye.
And I'm like, I'm
still into rough stuff.
I love all the MMA
and things like that.
I'm too fragile
to do it anymore,
but the first thing
I thought, seeing Par
with this tape above his
eye, he looks like a fighter.
And Par's pretty built.
He's got that fighter build.
And he comes walking in,
and rather than say, hey,
I'm Arno, sorry about your
dad, I was like, dude,
what happened to your eye?
Did you get in a
brawl or something?
Par goes on to tell me
that a week earlier, he's
bathing his son and daughter,
and his wife's at work.
His daughter is 7.
His son was 4.
And his daughter is
getting to the stage,
as a little kid, of being
self-conscious about being
naked.
So she's like, dad,
when I'm taking a bath,
don't look at me.
And Par's like, he wants
to oblige his daughter,
but he also needs
to get everywhere
or his wife's going
to let him have it
if he's not scrubbing
her down right.
So he's scrubbing
while looking away,
but he's got to peek and make
sure he's getting everywhere,
and then peek away.
Scrub, scrub, peek, peek away.
In the corner of the bathtub,
he's going one of them
shower organizers.
It's like spring loaded.
It goes between the bathroom
corner of the ceiling
and you got little
shelves where you
put your shampoos and whatnot.
And hanging off these shelves
are these little loofa hooks.
And Par's wife, Priti, is like,
Par, you got to get rid of them
hooks.
Somebody's going to lose
an eye or something.
This is really dangerous.
And Par, like many husbands,
was like, yeah, oh, sure.
I'll get to it, only
he never gets to it.
So as he's scrubbing and peeking
and scrubbing and peeking,
he looks away and the hook
goes right into his eye,
like a hot knife
through butter, just
like through the
white of his eye
and then out above his
eyebrow, like a fishhook.
Just whoomp!
And so Par's got his face
attached to this contraption
and he pulls the
springs to get it out.
He comes up like this
and he's holding it.
What the hell am I going to do?
And his daughter, Amaris, there
was freaking out and screaming.
And she grabs it and
starts yanking on it.
Fortunately--
PARDEEP KALEKA: I could
hear my eye throbbing.
I was like, the eyeball's
going to come out, baby girl.
ARNO MICHAELIS: Fortunately,
Pardeep's an ex-police officer.
He's very cool under pressure.
So Amaris is hauling
on this hook.
Pardeep's like, baby girl.
You got to let go of the hook.
And so she lets
go and he gets up.
He goes to the mirror
and he takes it
out the way it comes in.
Blood goes flying everywhere.
He says, OK, kids, get dressed.
We're going to urgent care.
There's an urgent care
a couple blocks away.
He puts a towel over his eye.
He's got four-year-old
Jay in one arm.
He's got the phone
and the towel here.
Amaris is hanging on his
belt. He calls his wife
as he walked into urgent care.
Hey, honey, yeah.
You know that hook in the bath?
Yeah, you're going to
say, I told you so,
but yeah, it went in my eye.
She's like, you idiot.
So he gets to urgent
care, comes walking in.
They're like, nope, nope.
You got to go to
the emergency room.
We can't help you here.
PARDEEP KALEKA: We
don't see those.
ARNO MICHAELIS: So
just then, Priti
gets there, once again,
probably called you an idiot.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Oh, yeah.
ARNO MICHAELIS: It's an
I told you so moment.
Takes him to the real doctor,
and they take the hook out,
and the doctor's
like, Pardeep, you
are one of the luckiest people
I've ever met in my life.
And Pardeep's like, I don't
really feel very lucky.
And the doctor goes,
if it would have
been 2 millimeters the other
way, you'd have a glass eye.
But as it was, his eye was
OK, but it tore the muscle
that kept his eyelid up.
So like in true
Punjabi fabulousness,
he tapes his eyelid
up so he can see,
and then he's got
to manually blink,
bringing his bottom eyelid
up when the eye gets dry.
And so he tells me this story.
And I'm just like
all y'all were.
I'm just like, oh, ew, no.
I'm literally squirming
and feeling his pain.
And this empathy that I have for
the suffering he went through
on the spot just like broke
the ice, on both sides.
And for me also, I'm like
an almost fatal klutz.
Like I am my own worst enemy.
I have over 20 concussions,
and probably half of them
are self induced.
And so when he's telling
me about his klutziness,
I'm like this is my guy.
We've been separated at birth.
So we sat down and we
split some squash curry.
Spicy was level 7, I believe.
It was pretty banging.
PARDEEP KALEKA:
And we got drunk.
ARNO MICHAELIS: We were
actually drinking tea all night.
We got buzzed on
those places for sure.
We were pretty buzzed.
And I remember, we met at
6 PM and the restaurant
closes at 9 PM.
And it was almost 10
when King's like, Arno,
we closed like 45 minutes ago.
Could you guys wrap it up?
And it was amazing.
We just had this brilliant
discussion that was so open,
and throughout
this conversation,
I have to remind myself.
I'm like, dude, you're sitting
here talking to this dude
because one of your old
guys murdered his dad.
Because Par was so down to earth
and so genuine and so friendly.
We just had the
most amazing talk.
And as we talked, we
saw we had so much more
in common than different,
even though we're
born on opposite
sides of the planet.
Our family stories are
the polar opposite.
His family scrapped and clawed
to achieve the American dream
over 30 years.
I was born with the
American dream handed
to me on a silver platter.
All I had to do was execute,
and I spent my whole life
getting away from it.
But as we sat and talked, like
commonality after commonality
after commonality appeared,
to the point of where he was
saying his daughter's seven.
I'm like, when my
daughter was seven,
she had this thing
with her socks.
And you'd put her socks on, and
if that seam was like cocked
what-- you know
what I'm saying--
if it's cocked one way or
the other over her toes,
she'd just be like this and
just freeze and not go anywhere.
You got to take her shoes
off, put the socks back on.
And I'm telling
him that, and he's
like, my daughter does that.
We're talking about our dads.
Par's dad would never pay
anybody to fix nothing.
Whether he knows how
to fix it or not,
he's like, I'm
going to fix this.
This results in him
having the lawn mower
in pieces on the living room
carpet in the middle of winter,
much to his mother's horror.
And my dad did the
exact same thing.
So after all these
commonalities,
that was really where the idea
for Serve to Unite was born.
And we walked out of
there right away like we
were going to work together.
We're going to be doing
something together
from this point forward.
SPEAKER 1: So I want to
get to Serve to Unite,
but we do have
two mics, so we'll
get to audience questions.
So if people want
to start lining up.
But talk to us about Serve
to Unite, how you founded it
and the message of
your foundation.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Sure.
So Serve to Unite
was founded, I mean,
in response to the Sikh temple
shootings on August 5th.
And what we saw at that time
in Oak Creek, Wisconsin,
and it's still
happening right now,
is we were seeing a lot
of demographic change.
And we saw a lot of
people uncomfortable
with this demographic change.
And as we've been,
for the last six years
that we've been
traveling, we've been
able to go to many
communities around the United
States, small towns
who are uncomfortable
with this demographic change.
And so Serve to Unite was
really just to respond to that.
And eventually what
it started to do
was, in the spirit of
intentions, sometimes
intentions take you
into different spheres.
And then we started to get
into conversations about, OK,
how do we bring school
communities together?
How do we bring broad
How do we bring global
communities together?
And that's really
where Serve to Unite--
it is an organization, but
it's much more a calling.
And it's a calling, not
to say, you know what?
Serve to Unite, meaning oneness.
We as human beings
have to understand,
and the principles of
Christianity, Islam, Sikhism,
Judaism, all those
faiths, that we are
connected at a spiritual level.
And it makes no sense
to read anything else
into any scriptures that closes
you off rather than opens you
up to that fundamental truth.
And so that's what
Serve to Unite was, is,
and we were privileged
to be able to go
to different communities
and school communities
and be able to address some of
the rift that exists right now.
ARNO MICHAELIS: What we
do specifically in schools
is we do arts-driven service
learning and global engagement.
So we ask our students
what issues in society
they want to
address, and then we
facilitate service
learning projects,
often involving the arts,
to solve those problems.
So our students have
addressed things
like community police
relations, Islamophobia,
religious intolerance, racism,
homophobia, homelessness,
human trafficking,
genocide prevention,
Holocaust education.
And we do this in conjunction
with a really amazing roster
of people we call
global mentors, who
are people from
all over the world,
some former violent
extremists like myself,
some survivors like Pardeep,
all of whom have amazing stories
and do amazing work
in their own spheres.
We connect them live with our
students via Google Hangout,
and our students are then
like inspired by that story,
and also advise in a really
practical sense about how
to best carry out
these service projects.
The dean Uman Yana is
a dear friend of ours
and who's also appeared
on Google Talks,
a survivor of the
Rwandan genocide,
is one of our best
global mentors.
And she helps make all
this kind of stuff happen.
SPEAKER 1: Want to start?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you so much for coming.
I really appreciate you
coming and sharing your story.
Arno, you describe
an adolescence
that is very
hateful and violent,
but at the time of August
5th, your first reaction
is compassion.
As maybe an insight as to how
that transformation happens
to other people in
white supremacy orgs,
what was your story?
How did that transition
happen and how did you
escape that life?
ARNO MICHAELIS: That's
an awesome question.
The very quick answer to
how I got out of the moment
was exhaustion.
It was exhausting doing
that constant spin.
It was exhausting cutting myself
off from culture and media
that I had once
taken for granted.
What was most
exhausting was when
people who I claimed to hate
treated me with kindness.
And I was very fortunate that
during my seven-year span
in hate groups, there were times
when a Jewish boss, a lesbian
supervisor, black
and Latino coworkers,
treated me with kindness
when I least deserved it.
And I think this is crucial to
say, in our political climate
today, in treating
me with kindness,
they were actively defying
everything that I was about.
Everything I did back then
was meant to provoke hatred.
It was meant to
provoke hostility.
If the hate was directed
at me, all the better.
So when people got angry at
me and they wanted to fight,
I was like, yes.
Let the aggression flow.
That's what I'm
trying to make happen.
So the people who treated me
with kindness were like, no.
You're not making
the rules here.
I'm making the rules.
And the rules are, this is how
human beings treat each other.
If you grow up, you
can live in this world
where you're not
terrified of everyone.
And that's what got me out.
I was very fortunate also--
within a couple of years
of leaving this white power
skinhead life, I started
going to rave parties.
So I'm a man of extremes.
I go from extreme
hate and violence
to extreme peace and love.
So a couple of years out
from beating people up
because of the
color of their skin,
I'm on the south side
of Chicago at 4:00
in the morning on a
Sunday, shaking my ass
to house music with 4,000 people
of every possible ethnicity,
gender, identity,
sexual orientation,
socioeconomic background
on the planet Earth,
and loving every minute of it.
And the people in
the rave scene--
I used to have
swastikas back on me.
Like this whole arm was
a big pile of swastikas.
And people were just like, it
doesn't matter where you were.
It matters where you are.
And we accept you.
You're forgiven,
unconditionally on the spot.
That was really a huge
part of my re-humanizing.
It was a huge part of
my learning and growth.
And I was still being
very self-destructive.
I had added profuse drug
use to my profuse drinking,
and selling drugs for
a while, but it was
definitely a big step forward.
And so eventually
I quit drinking.
That was another
big step forward.
Brought some more
challenges because
without alcohol to numb my past,
it almost consumed me again.
Fortunately, my daughter
led me out of that,
and I started writing in 2007.
Writing's a really
powerful process.
I started meditating in 2009,
and my meditation practice
is really what empowers me
to do everything I'm doing.
I think without it, I
wouldn't be able to.
So that was really
how I got from being
where I was to where I am now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARNO MICHAELIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being
here and sharing your story.
For those of us who are inspired
by the themes of empathy
and understanding different
perspectives, what do you see
is the role that technology
can play in that?
So for those of us who
work on Google products,
or the many Google
products that exist
in some capacity
or another, do you
see there's a way that
any products could
be different to help with
the concepts of empathy
and helping each other,
understand each other's
perspectives?
PARDEEP KALEKA: Yeah, yeah.
Great question, and
where we are right now.
And I think technology
is something
that's going to be part of
our lives going forward.
It's not something
we can put back in
and say, well you know what?
We want to engage
in human contact
like we are doing right now.
With that said, I
think there's a lot
to be said for the
benefits of technology.
I'm a therapist
now, and I see a lot
of clients who have had
very traumatic pasts,
and we have a lot of suicidal
ideation, homicidal ideation.
One of the things, one of
the tools, that actually,
believe it or not,
keeps them living
and keeps them connected to
the world is the virtual world.
Now, we have to be
careful in our algorithms,
and not siloing a person who is
miserable towards more misery.
So actively challenging the
silo that someone exists in,
having them critically
think, those
are those things we can all
do, but don't underestimate
your power with technology
into keeping somebody
from committing a horrible
act against themselves
or somebody else.
One of the first things that--
I forget the name of the
shooter in Sandy Hook--
ARNO MICHAELIS: Adam Lanza.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Adam Lanza--
one of the first things
he did was, he put a bullet
through his computer.
Right?
And so once you start to
do that, those are threads
of humanity, and threads of
humanity, the more threads
to humanity that you have,
the more stable you can be,
the more of a support
structure you can have.
So the most dangerous
person is the person who
feels rejected and isolated.
Rejection, whether it's
real or whether it's
conceived through self
persecution, paranoia,
is real to that person.
And we have to understand
that first and foremost.
The next school shooter, and
I hate to say it in this way,
to assume that there's
going to be a next one,
but the school year is
going to start up soon,
is most likely feeling rejected,
most likely feeling isolated.
And that could be
for real things.
Something could be
happening, or it
could be just the delusions
or the chemical imbalance
that that person has.
But technology goes a long way
as far as making a person not
feel like they're by themselves.
But it can also,
with any good thing,
there can be the flip side.
Right?
And we can go really bad
and make them feel even more
isolated and more suffer.
So I don't know if that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for sharing your story.
That was really powerful.
It resonated with me personally
on multiple different levels,
one of which is I actually
work at Google Ideas.
It's super cool to
hear that from--
ARNO MICHAELIS: Right on.
AUDIENCE: --from Against
Violent Extremism.
I guess my concern is,
similar to the last one,
but there are a lot of
debates about free speech
and technology, and what
role tech companies, who
are platforms, should say.
And you talk about rejection
and feeling isolated,
but there's also
obviously radicalization
that happens in communities.
I guess I'm just curious what
your general thoughts are
on that.
ARNO MICHAELIS: And
thank you once again.
Obviously, the Against
Violence Extremism network,
beyond just
connecting Par and I,
has been like the backbone
of Serve to Unite.
Many of our global mentors
have been connected with us
through the Against
Violent Extremism network.
And I've been doing counter
violent extremism work
internationally since the
Summit Against Violent
Extremism in the summer of '11,
which Google Ideas made happen.
So that was huge.
Following up on the technology
thing, and as part managing it,
the toothpaste is
out of the tube.
It's not going back in.
That's just the way it is.
And technology can be
immensely empowering
or it can be insidiously evil.
Fire can burn down
your house or it
can keep you alive in the
winter when it's freezing.
It's just how we employ it
that really makes a difference.
And as far as technology
and free speech go,
I think that I'm a huge
proponent of free speech.
I love the First Amendment.
I think it's probably one of
the best things about the United
States of America.
I am very much
opposed to legislation
against hate speech.
I think it has never
accomplished less hate.
Countries like England
and Germany and Sweden,
where hate speech is
disallowed, have huge problems
with far right
gangs because what
it does is, it validates
the victimhood narrative
of this game.
So if I'm in the
UK and I'm like,
I can't even say this
word without them
oppressing me and
putting me in jail,
that's a means of recruitment.
It's a means of cultivating
the white victimhood that's
at the base of all that.
And that goes if you're
talking about Islamist groups
or whatever.
There's no violent
extremism narrative
that doesn't revolve around
a sense of oppression.
And whether that oppression
is real or imagined
is completely beside the point.
It's real to the
people who feel it.
And without that
sense of oppression,
they're not going to be
angry enough to hurt people.
So when the
government is actively
adding to the
oppression by saying,
hey, you can't say this
word without going to jail,
it helps hate groups grow.
That being said, being a
proponent of free speech
as I am, I think if
we love free speech,
and I love how the ACLU
works in this regard,
the more you love free
speech, the more responsible
you should be with your speech.
If the government isn't going
to say, you can say this
and you can't say
that, it's up to you
to have the personal
responsibility to say,
I'm not going to yell fire
right now in this crowded venue
because it would
cause a stampede.
Someone could get hurt.
That's my responsibility
as someone
who enjoys the benefits
of the First Amendment,
is to be extra responsible
and mindful with my language.
It's not the polar opposite,
which is what we see,
So like free speech,
rah, rah, rah.
They want to say all the most
offensive things they can.
To me, it's not showing any
gratitude for your ability
to speak freely.
So I think it's being
responsible, being mindful,
is really important.
In a technological sense, I
think technology companies
like Google--
and you guys have done
an amazing job at this--
need to be very
aware of the power
that the platform carries.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Just to
piggyback on that real quick,
the First Amendment and
the Second Amendment
came out in times when like,
what types of guns did we have?
What type of free
press did we have?
What type of speech did we have?
If we think about it in terms
of the current situation
that we're in, we're thinking
about speech, press, weapons,
and thinking as far as we can
do weapons of mass destruction,
or words of mass
destruction, or words
of mass togetherness or
weapons of mass togetherness.
So it's just
completely amplified.
And so, I mean, you guys are the
experts in this kind of field.
But we need to get to a
place where a person is not
elected because they have the
most social media followers.
We have celebrities who don't
say the smartest things,
but yet they get a
million retweets.
We have celebrity
stardom, and it's
like, but when is it that we
get the voice back to the people
who are actually
leaders, thought leaders,
in these fields?
So a great question.
SPEAKER 1: We have time
for a very, very quick one.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thank you so much for
being here and sharing
the story for goodness.
I think I really needed it.
I'm a Googler.
I'm an MBA intern.
And I go to school
in Charlottesville.
So when I heard you saying,
August 5th, August 5th,
I kept thinking August
12th because I was there
when Heather was murdered.
And it's a wound
every year, right?
This year, I'm going to be our
vice president of diversity
at Darden and I've had
people messaging and calling
me, saying, what do I do because
it feels like the wound has
been ripped again?
And so I'm curious
what advice you all
have for me to share with
my peers in the community
down in Charlottesville
about how we move on,
when hundreds of people
like you were there,
right, protesting hate.
We might not have the ability
to stay and have a conversation,
as you all are having.
So what advice do I give to
my peers and to my community
when I go back?
Today's my last day, by the way.
But hopefully I'll
be back here in May.
So what advice
would you give me?
PARDEEP KALEKA: Advice for
that, I would give anybody,
is just to honor that pain.
I think, in our
country's history,
there has been this
sort of an appetite
to move forward without
honoring pain from the past.
And like I said before, we can
build a society around wounds.
Sure, we can, but
until we actually
address the wound that
exists there by honoring it,
we don't really move
forward because we all
know that it's there.
We all know that
it's there because we
can't have conversations around
race without somebody getting
uncomfortable.
And then, that uncomfortability
speaks to, hey,
you know what, there's
something still there that
needs to be addressed.
So I'm sorry for what happened
on August 12th and Heather
Heyer, and really, her
life needs to be honored.
One of the saddest
things that I saw
was, from a lot of social media,
as whether like white allies
should be honored.
And I'm like, how is this
even in a conversation?
How are we getting to
the point in society
that we are actually
having a conversation
on whether a person who lost
their life, as a martyr,
is a life worth honoring?
And so I thank you
for speaking up.
I realize that
you are her voice.
ARNO MICHAELIS: I
think it's really--
and again, I'm so grateful
for your dedication
to bring about a society
where everyone is valued
and included, and I
bear witness to the pain
that you're feeling over
what happened to Heather
and over all the other violence
that happened that day.
In that spirit, I want to
empower you and everyone
you work with to truly
defy hate and violence.
And in all candor,
in all frankness,
some people not understanding
that help to contribute to what
happened in Charlottesville.
There's a lot of people
who rightfully believe
that going out and
punching Nazis,
and we can somehow out-hate
them, or hate them out
of existence, and it feeds them.
It's the best gift
you can give them.
It doesn't defy them.
You're actually
putty in their hands
when you respond to them
with any kind of aggression
because that's what
they're trying to provoke.
In Serve to Unite, we work
with kids from second grade
through college,
and every year, we
have a peace summit where we
get all our students together
in one spot.
The first year we did this,
we had over 400 students
from second grade
through college,
in historic Turner's
Ballroom in Milwaukee.
They spent the day doing
collaborative art projects
and networking and sharing
their service projects
they did all year.
We had music and food.
It was a lot of fun.
And the last thing that day was
our second and third graders
from Escuela Fratney,
who were this absolutely
gorgeous diverse spectrum of
ethnicities and backgrounds
up stage, little tiny kids,
and they taught the whole crowd
to sing a song of
piece called Salaam
where the verse is in Hebrew
and the chorus is in Arabic,
and you're singing it around.
And pretty soon, we have
400 kids from second grade
through college, who have
every possible background you
can imagine, singing about
peace in Hebrew and Arabic,
after spending the day
together, loving each other,
seeing each other's
humanity, valuing each other,
collaborating to solve
problems in society.
And as this is going on,
I'm thinking to myself,
this is a white supremist's
worst nightmare.
And this is how we
respond to hate crime.
This is what you get.
If you want to come
and shoot up a temple,
you want to come drive
a car into people,
you want to commit this
kind of violence and hatred,
this is how we're
going to respond.
And if everybody would get board
with that kind of response,
I shit you not, we can put an
end to white power rallies.
I have a blog at
mylifeafterhate.com--
I have an article there, how
to smash neo-Nazi events.
And I implore you to
read that and share it.
I really think that showing the
beauty and power of diversity,
winning in the marketplace of
ideas, is how we defeat hate.
And it's really important to
not let yourself play their game
and not to let them
make the rules.
PARDEEP KALEKA: Real
quick, the response
has to be so much stronger
than the action committed,
and with that said, when
August 5th happened,
and one of the
producers for a show
asked me one time, Pardeep, why
do you say the shooter's name?
There's so many people,
survivors, that he interviewed,
and he's like, they don't
ever say the shooter's name.
And I told him, I
said, quite honestly, I
want to remind the Wade Michael
Pages of the world that are out
there that are watching this
that what happens when you do
something like this
because you're hateful,
because whatever you believe
in, because you're miserable,
you think that you're going to
make other people miserable?
But this made us stronger
and this made us better.
The response was
so much stronger,
that I wanted to remind, and
that's the greatest violence
prevention technique
that you can use,
is make the response
so much stronger
than the action committed.
And say, well, look
at what happened
because of what you did.
Then, think twice about
what you're about to do.
When we're miserable
because of the response,
or because of the
actual committed,
then the shooter or the person
committing violence has won.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: Guys, thank
you for being here.
ARNO MICHAELIS: Thank you, guys.